have you ever shown a friend a movie
only to hear them say I don't get it as
the credits roll look everyone has their
own tastes and that's great but
sometimes a confusion and disconnect
actually comes from the movie itself
being intentionally confusing High
concept or just clumsily made let's go
over some of these films that make
people say huh and Pat ourselves on the
back for the ones we know inside and out
spoilers
ahead no that's a proper introduction
arrival this 2016 alien invasion film
offers a Twist on the popular genre by
focusing the Plus on efforts to
communicate with the aliens across a
very tricky language barrier it's a
slower more low-key storyline we spend
most of the movie with Amy Adams's
well-renowned linguist character as she
tries connecting with the interstellar
beings and begins to understand their
complex language as the movie goes along
we also get to see flashes of her
character in another life caring for a
daughter that we as the audience know is
doomed to Die Young while it's natural
to assume that what we're seeing of
flashbacks it turns out we're witnessing
a tragedy that actually hasn't happened
yet we learn at the film's climax along
with Adam's character that the aliens
have their own more circular way of
perceiving time and the bond that they
build with Adams ends up allowing her to
see into the future as they do while
it's among 2016's most critically
acclaimed wide releases arriv rival
earned a be Cinema score suggesting a
decent number of people walked away
somewhat confused with its complicated
somewhat challenging plot twist that's
understandable but ultimately a shame
this flick is truly a cinematic joy and
then on the other side of the spectrum
Batman versus Superman dawn of Justice
this movie isn't confusing because it's
too smart for the audience or anything
like that it's mostly that it just
doesn't make any sense from Wonder
Woman's motivations to the basic
structure of the plot Batman versus
Superman is a movie that barely hangs
together and only scrapes by thanks to
sounds and spectacle the heavily
criticized Martha moment wasn't just a
heads scratching failure because it was
was weird even though it totally was the
real problem was that it just wasn't
enough to explain why Batman would
suddenly decide to not fulfill a mission
he'd pursued obsessively to this
point this movie does a lot to convince
us that Batman believes with absolute
certainty that Superman is a danger to
the world so it really doesn't make
sense that having a mother with the same
name would be enough to deter Batman and
even have him describe himself as
Superman's friend just a few scenes
later I'm a friend of yourself
I
figured the cape this coupled with the
movie's unexplained dream sequences and
Jesse eisenberg's nutso version of Lex
Luther makes the film feel fundamentally
illogical incomplete and frustrating
lots of longtime fans of these
characters were pretty upset with how
the movie handled the source material
and if Batman versus Superman was
someone's introduction to the DC
Universe they probably left the theater
wondering what the hell they just got
themselves into only God forgives
Nicholas winding Reen and Ryan Gosling
followed up their dreamy and fantastic
film drive with a hard left turn into
the abstract with 2013's only God
forgives taking the action to Thailand
goling stars as essentially a way less
interesting non driving version of his
character from drive he spends a big
chunk of the movie wandering through the
dreamy Bangkok cityscape leaving
audiences to wonder what the hell is
going on if that wasn't weird enough
putting enough we're also treated to
surreal karaoke sequences from a
character called both Lieutenant Chang
and the angel of death and described by
the director as quote a mythological
creature that has a mysterious past but
cannot relate to reality because he's
heightened and he's pure fetish uh okay
the entire movie is kind of like that
and it's not hard to imagine that some
folks left the theater feeling worried
that they weren't smart enough to
understand it well here's some good news
there's not actually much going on in
this overblown film for anyone who left
the movie feeling confused don't sweat
it you were totally justified none of
this makes any sense
Prometheus fans and critics alike have
talked about this movies puzzling
failures quite a bit but there are
plenty of good reasons to do so
especially when you consider just how
much potential Prometheus had the film
is an ambiguous prequel in the alien
film franchise but it unfortunately
confused audiences with everything from
its character's basic motivations to its
strange
conclusion I think there might be some
confusion about our relationship the
truth is that Prometheus almost works
but it falls short as it spends a lot of
time hinting at pluton story while
failing to actually deliver the
necessary parts that make an audience
care even longtime fans were unable to
connect to anything happening in front
of them during Prometheus it was so
weird and fundamentally unsatisfying
that it's no surprise the franchise is
eager to get some distance from this one
Prometheus 2 has been renamed alien
Covenant and fans hopes are high that it
can bring the franchise back to form the
but Butterfly Effect serious actor
Ashton Kutcher's the butterfly effect is
one of the dumbest movies ever to remain
essentially watchable while being
completely illogical at the same time
while you might think the movie makes
sense if you take even a second to
really think about the plot it totally
falls apart Kutcher's protagonist is
blessed or perhaps cursed with the
ability to use old personal tokens to
phase back through time to memorable
moments in his life and so he spends the
bulk of the movie trying to fix his
mistakes usually only to emerge in
situations that are even worse the
premise and Baseline rule of the movie
that the slightest change can alter the
course of your life entirely gets thrown
out of the window time and time again
whenever the script deems it necessary
in one scene as Kucha tries to defend
himself inside a violent prison he goes
back in time to stab his hands
frightening the other inmates with his
sudden new wounds but if going back in
time to change the slightest thing
changes everything then why is Kucha
still in jail why did the wounds appear
as if by Magic instead of appearing
scarred over after what should have been
an entire life of having them is it
really worth it to try and figure out
this movie's logic well no so if you
don't get this one don't worry too much
no one really does it's a great example
of a pretty good idea that ultimately
was poorly executed and left much to be
desired ah
well a mysterious sex box a 150 year
long dream and so many time Loops these
Sci-Fi movies still have audiences
scratching their heads
Stanley Kubrick's 2001 A Space Odyssey
is considered one of the great sci-fi
Classics and one of the most revered
Works in film history the 1968 picture
pushed the boundaries of special effects
lifted sci-fi from bovie schlock to
Serious art and made everyone afraid of
killer computers after escaping the
clutches of Hal 9000 astronaut Dave
Bowman is sucked into a Trippy Tunnel
right outside Jupiter he's assaulted
with all sorts of lights and crazy
colors before winding up in a cold
soulless hotel room in just a matter of
minutes Bowman turns into an old man and
that's when a black monolith appears at
the foot of his bed these monoliths have
been turning up the entire movie
sparking new stages of evolution
whenever they appear when Dave reaches
out to the big black Obelisk he turns
into a glowing space fetus this magical
floating baby is known as the star child
and in the film's final sequence it
floats out into the Galaxy looking down
at Earth did Dave literally transform to
an alien infant is the star child
symbolic of Humanity's next stage in
evolution could it mean something else
alt together it doesn't seem like we'll
ever know for sure its origin and
purpose still a total mystery AI
artificial intelligence is a thoroughly
depressing Affair after all this is the
film where Haley Joel Osman breaks down
crying because his mom abanded him in
the woods granted Osman is playing a
lifelike Android named David but still
you can't just toss a heartbroken Mecca
into the wild after all the world is
cruel to little Androids poor David is
bullied by human kids sees his fellow
robots ripped apart and eventually finds
himself stuck at the bottom of the ocean
desperately wishing he could become a
real boy it's a wish that will never
come true and then there's that ending
after 2,000 years of solitude David is
rescued by evolved AI the creatures take
pity on the little Mecca and using
Advanced Tech they give David one last
day with his mother
that's how the movie ends with David
cuddling his mom happy at last some
casual viewers had no problem with the
ending but many sci-fi fans were
outraged at the shift in tone placing
the blame squarely on director Steven
Spielberg AI was originally a Stanley
kubric project so many assumed Spielberg
screwed up Kubrick's Dark Project by
attacking on the sappy finale as
Spielberg eventually pointed out however
the whole David gets to spend one last
day with his mother thing was actually
Kubrick's idea more importantly it isn't
a happy ending the evolved Mecca are
granting David's wish because they're
about to shut him down forever they're
going to kill this little kid and we're
watching his final hallucination before
he's put down if that's not a kubric
ending then we don't know what is
Richard Kelly's CT classic Donnie Darko
hit theaters in 2001 but fans are still
trying to solve this incredibly complex
sci-fi flick to this day the plot
follows the titular Donnie an angsty
high schooler who narrowly avoids death
by a falling jet engine thanks to a 6
tall rabbit named Frank if that isn't
crazy enough the film soon introduces
the concepts of time travel and
Alternate Dimensions turning a Coming of
Age tale into a cryptic head scratcher
you're
weird sorry now that was a compliment
there's a lot of questions raised by
Donnie Darko that you probably won't see
the answers to on your first viewing we
know Donnie has to stop an apocalypse
but what exactly does that have to do
with wormholes how do deceased
characters come back to life what's up
with that demonic Bunny and why is
Donnie wearing that stupid human suit
it's all so complicated that Kelly felt
the need to release a director's cut to
help fans put the pieces together Donnie
Darko is a movie that demands rewatch
after rewatch and while it's possible to
gain a decent understanding of the plot
there's no denying that it's a mad movie
before introducing the world to the
cheddar Goblin in his 2018 film Mandy
director Panos cosmatos broke onto the
Cinematic scene with Beyond the Black
rainbow this psychedelic night of a
movie features a telekinetic girl and a
slasher scientist who find themselves in
a battle of life and death it's been
compared to films like elpo and a raser
head and according to its creator the
film's screenplay is only 11 pages long
as you might expect this is a movie that
takes its sweet time drowning audiences
with surreal images and sounds that make
you wonder if you're watching a film or
going on an acid trip the movie prompts
so many questions what's really
happening at the arboria Institute
what's up with that glowing crystal and
what exact happens to the villainous Dr
Nile after he goes beyond the black
Rainbow by the time you come down from
this incredibly disturbing trip you'll
either immediately want more or you'll
have completely lost your mind exmachina
is a creepy film that examines what
might happen when Humanity finally
creates artificial intelligence and what
might happen nothing good that's a
lesson that Caleb learns the hard way
after he's invited to participate in an
advanced touring test by billionaire
Tech genius Nathan the programming
Prodigy wants Caleb to see if his
imprisoned Android an AI named Ava is
capable of independent thought the only
hitch is that Ava looks like Alicia
Vander and Caleb starts to fall for her
you're
impressed yes
yes although
although there's a qualification to you
being impressed Ava and Caleb seem to
grow close and after realizing Nathan is
a monster who's creating female androids
for his own sick gratification Caleb
decides to break Ava loose he hopes they
can run away together and Ava seems
totally cool with Caleb's plan but once
she's free she kills Nathan and locks up
Caleb leaving him to die as she sets out
into the real world her decision left a
lot of viewers baffled why kill such a
nice guy well Caleb might not have been
as glaringly evil as Nathan but he only
treats Ava like a human once he starts
falling in love with her even though
he's more polite he still views Ava like
an object in the same way that Nathan
does he only decides to help her Escape
after Ava flirts with him and makes him
feel special meanwhile she's tired of
being a slave so it's time for her to
finally take control directed by
Christopher Nolan Inception is a bizarre
Blockbuster where cities fold on top of
themselves trains appear out of nowhere
and hotels spin around like crashing
cars in other words it's a movie about
the power of Dreams Inception takes
place in the subconscious where rules
can be bent and mental barriers
manipulated but for all its incredible
imagery the film sparked so much
conversation because of a simple
spinning top the plot of this sci-fi
epic follows a group of Thieves led by
the enigmatic Dominic Cobb as they try
to implant an idea in the mind of a
young business Heir if cob can complete
the mission he'll have his murky past
erased and he'll finally get to return
to the US and see his kids again and
wouldn't you know it the mission is a
success and in the film's final moments
Cobb is reunited with his children maybe
there's actually a good chance that Cobb
might be asleep stuck in limbo for the
rest of his life everything depends on
that Infamous top if Cobb is in the real
world it will topple over eventually but
if he's still asleep it will keep on
spinning forever the movie Cuts right as
the top starts to wobble which resulted
in Endless debate about Cobb's fate
according to Christopher Nolan however
it's not such a big deal if the top
falls over or not as the Director
explained the important thing for Cobb
is that he's back with his kids whether
this is reality or it's all in his head
the only thing that matters is that it's
real for him finding love is hard enough
but if you've only got 45 days to find a
mate or be morphed into an animal that
makes things a lot more difficult
unfortunately for poor David if he
doesn't find a partner in a a few weeks
he'll be tossed into a mysterious
machine and turned into a lobster
however things start looking up when he
meets the shortsighted woman in this
Society Partners have to share a
physical similarity and since they both
suffer from vision problems it seems
they're a match until she is blinded
this leaves the lovers in a tricky
situation if they want to make this work
David will have to Blind himself too I'm
going to do it with a
knife do you want me to come with you
I'd rather you didn't as the short woman
Waits at a diner Booth David stands in
front of a bathroom mirror with a steak
Knife just centimet from his own eyeball
before we can see anything though the
film cuts to the short-sighted woman
sitting at her table she waits and waits
for David to return but the film goes
black before audiences can learn if
David did the bloody deed not even the
cast and crew of The Lobster know the
truth speaking with Entertainment Weekly
Colin Ferrell revealed that director
yorgos Lanos and screenwriter eamus
filipo never came up with an answer for
the film's end
as for himself phell can see it going
either way he joked honest to God part
of me thinks he does it then part of me
thinks that when the camera Cuts back to
Rachel Vice I'm already in a uber
heading down the road as fast as I can
the actor also raised the possibility
that David could have faked blindness so
he could be with his lover while still
maintaining his eyesight whatever your
interpretation might be it probably says
a lot about the way you view romance
written directed by and starring Justin
Benson and Aaron Morehead 2017's the
endless follows two brothers who escaped
a UFO cult when they were younger but
are lured back by a strange videotape
once they arrive freaky things start
happening and they start to get the
feeling that there's something evil
hiding in the darkness by the time the
credits roll the endless has posed a lot
of complicated questions what's up with
the entity and the time Loops what's
with those freaky statues and why is
there a crossover with Benson and
morehead's earlier movie resolution well
the invisible demon haunting our heroes
is a standin for horror movie audiences
who like their stories to have dark
endings and as it turns out the creature
drew the brothers back to the cult in
hopes of trapping them in a Time Loop
this particular desert is crowded with
different Loops some which last seconds
and others which stretch on for decades
if you D in the loop or submit yourself
to the Beast you'll be trapped forever
that's why the cult members look so
young they've been repeating the same
cycle every 10 years at the end of each
Loop The Entity tears them to shreds and
they start over again it's all part of
the creatures need for scary stories
with violent endings it turns out that
the guys from resolution are stuck in a
Time Loop of their own a revelation that
adds new depth to the 2012 film as for
those monuments they all represent the
evil entity they were constructed by the
victims stuck in the loops and they're
meant to express how these poor souls
viewed the demon judging by the apparent
age of some of these sculptures it seems
like this interdimensional creature has
been trapping people for a very long
time Christopher Nolan's 2020 sci-fi
flick tenant just might be the
filmmaker's most confusing movie yet met
with lukewarm reception by critics tenet
is a high concept puzzle box that's more
interested in giving the viewer Clues to
solve it rather than answers hell
happened
here it hasn't happened yet the
protagonist is a CIA agent who finds a
mysterious artifact during a mission
when the artifact is stolen from him
he's recruited by a time traveling
organization called tenant to retrieve
it the protagonist and his Handler Neil
travel the globe to recover the artifact
but nothing and no one is as it seems
that sounds straightforward enough but
things are never so simple in a
Christopher Nolan movie and the ending
of tenant is one of his most confounding
the film's core narrative centers around
the concept of time inversion that means
the entropy of objects from the future
can move backwards so things from the
future can get brought into the past
those in the present move forward while
the future moves backward at least in
the present to achieve this effect of
two opposite movements at the same time
Nolan shot the time inversion action
sequences twice one normally and the
other with the actors moving backwards
getting your head around the concept of
time inversion is the first key to
unlocking the rest of tenant most
viewers are bound to get lost their
first time around as the movie breaks
down linear time to render it a circle
that's why even the movie's biggest
Defenders say it takes another trip
around to really get it to click whether
it's the sight of a skeletal bear or a
man turned into a fungus Annihilation is
a movie that sticks in your mind but
even more compelling than the gigantic
shark Gator is the film's ambiguous
ending after heading deep into the
Shimmer an Ever growing electromagnetic
wave that mixes and matches DNA biology
Professor Lena encounters a metallic
humanoid that tries to copy her likeness
using a grenade Lena kills the
doppelganger and burns down the Shimmer
but while she saved the world that
doesn't mean it's smooth sailing for our
hero Lena's whole reason for heading
into the Shimmer was to discover what
happened to her husband Kane he's a
soldier who went MIA after heading into
into the world's freakiest light show
and then a year later he suddenly
appeared out of nowhere deathly ill
hoping to save his life and ease her
guilt Lena accompanies four other women
into the Shimmer to figure out exactly
what's going on what she learns is
haunting the cane back at the hospital
is almost certainly a doppelganger much
like the one that tried to take Lena's
place however there's something odd
about the Lena who finally escapes the
Shimmer when she hugs her clone husband
we see the color in her eyes dance and
wave much like the lights in the Shimmer
did the real Lena make it back home or
was she replaced by the doppelganger
somewhere during their struggle or
perhaps the Shimmer altered her DNA and
turned her into something new whatever
happened Lena is a new person forever
changed after literally confronting
herself inspired by the French short
film L Terry gilam brings a fresh set of
eyes to an Old-Fashioned time travel
Tale in 12 Monkeys the killer cast and
gorgeous production design are enough to
get viewers to still return to this 1995
classic even if the ending is a bit
mind-boggling in a post-apocalyptic 2035
James Cole is a prison inmate sent back
in time to stop the virus that destroyed
Humanity he travels back to 1996 to
track down the source of the virus but
is continuously haunted by dreams of a
little boy seeing a man shot at an
airport in the end he finally catches up
with Dr Peters who's heading to an
airport to start the virus outbreak Cole
tries to stop the doctor and instead is
shot by the police as it turns out his
dreams weren't dreams at all they were
memories of his younger self watching
his future self get killed the purpose
of Cole's tragic life is just one of
many questions left at the end of 12
Monkeys we never get to see if any of
Cole's actions changed the timeline but
it's heavily implied that his actions
were fruitless nothing will change the
past stays the same and the future is
unavoidable the whole Affair is a bleak
take on time travel that appreciates
repeat viewings the movie never changes
it can't change but I can't every time
you see it it seems different because
you are different stalker is a classic
but by today's standards it's definitely
a slow movie watching Andre tarkovsky's
1979 cerebral work of post-apocalyptic
sci-fi is a test of patience but for
those who have stuck with it the reward
has been great over the years many
people have watched this movie and
walked away with different stabs at its
meaning a deeply interpretive film
stalker is as confounding as it is
profound based on Arcy and Boris strat's
Nolla roadside picnic three men the
writer the professor and the stalker go
into the radioactive Zone with which
contains a mythical wish granting room
the trio Ventures through a dangerous
land of paranormal anomalies and
unexplained phenomena all while
philosophically sparring with each other
and exploring their motivations for the
journey when they finally reach the room
however there is an inexplicable
anticlimax as the three men sit in
silence what happens inside the room and
the significance of their journey is
left entirely ambiguous what exactly is
the zone and how has it changed the
people who dare enter it the final shots
of the movie show that the stalker's
daughter has now gained superhuman
Powers which are implied to be a result
of his journey this question and others
are asked from the very beginning of
stalker and its lack of answers still
Sparks vigorous discussion over 40 years
later if you're at all familiar with
predestination paradoxes you might have
some idea of where this Ethan Hawk
sci-fi thriller is headed predestination
is based off of Robert a heinlin 1959
science fiction short story all you
zombies this 2014 sci-fi puzzle Stars
Hawk as agent a disfigured time
traveling agent Who moonlights as a
barkeep after a failed attempt to stop
the bomber that wounded him one day in
1970 agent doe meets a man called JN who
reveals that he was born an intersex
female named Jane and had a child who
was stolen by an unknown man
complications during birth led to forc
gender reassignment surgery so Jane
began living as Jon agent doe takes Jon
back in time to 1963 to get revenge on
the man who created this situation only
to realize that Jon is the person who
got Jane himself pregnant so agent do
takes Jane's baby further back in time
to 1945 and the child grows up into Jane
this is the predestination Paradox and
it only gets more complicated as the
movie continues by the end it is
revealed the movie is about a single
character the agent and the bomber are
also the same person as John Jane and
the baby and it's it's a paradox right
but it can't be
parado after learning who he will become
the agent kills the bomber and tries to
close his own Lo that's where
predestination ends leaving us to
imagine J's endless Nightmare and wonder
about the logic and existential
questions behind it all Robert patson
fans might follow the dreamy actor to
the ends of the Earth but apparently not
beyond our solar system at least that's
how the reaction to 2018s high life
would make it seem while many critics
found CLA Denise erotic sci-fi drama
mesmerizing and thought-provoking a
majority of the audience seem to
disagree this is likely due to the slow
pacing and cryptic methods of
Storytelling that that Deni utilizes
Monty is a criminal on death row who's
been placed on a ship full of convicted
Killers heading towards a black hole he
and the others are subject to
experiments run by the mysterious Dr
dibs who controls sexual activity on the
ship Monty manages to father a child and
he works to keep himself and his baby
alive amidst the intense psychological
pressure of Dr dib's experiments high
life is focused on sex but many viewers
are still unsure about what exactly the
movie has to say about sexuality thanks
to its dreamlike quality its most
puzzled aspect is its representation of
the Box a room that the prisoners Ed to
stimulate themselves Den described
herself as Pro sex in an interview with
slate and clarified that she sees the
box as something positive however in an
interview with GQ she also said that she
herself doesn't actually know what high
life is about saying I'm not interested
in understanding honestly it's not a
joke I don't need to understand I need
to feel good about something that's all
I need although Cameron Crow's 2001
sci-fi Adventure was a critical
punchline in its day Vanilla Sky Has
Gone on to gain a cult following this
ambitious Thriller is an English
language remake of Alejandro aminar open
your eyes a Trippy warning about the
dangers of technology and vanity
narcissistic Playboy David Ames is in a
horrific car accident after his jealous
girlfriend Julie discovers his
relationship with another woman Sophia
after recovering David rejoins society
and starts daating Sophia again but his
reality starts to disintegrate in
strange ways the ending of Vanilla Sky
reveals that the movie has taken place
inside David's lucid dream that has been
going on for 150 years after disfiguring
his face and losing Sophia in reality
David opted to exist in a cryogenic
hypersleep inside a dream where he can
live a fantasy life until the technology
needed to repair his face is perfected
his idealized fantasy world gets ruined
by a glitch in the system so David is
given the choice to either stay in the
dream or leap off the roof to break the
illusion and return to reality look at
this I'm frozen and you're
dead and I love you what David
ultimately chooses and what it
represents is unclear he decides to jump
and break free from his dream but he
doesn't know for certain if he will wake
up or what the world will even look like
now after so much time in the final
moments we hear a woman's voice call to
him but it's not clear whether he has
made it to reality or if he has finally
passed away the Bittersweet romantic
drama Eternal Sunshine of the Spotless
Mind is a collaboration between
surrealism experts Charlie Kaufman and
Michelle gandre when Joel and Clementine
break up they both decide to undergo a
procedure to have their memories of each
other erased the majority of the film
takes place in Joel's mind as he recalls
his doomed relationship with Clementine
as the memories get deleted after going
through the procedure he retains one
vague recollection of Clementine telling
him to meet her in monok where they
first met despite the procedure's
success both lovers find each other
again in monok and start again even
after learning the truth of their
chaotic and painful relationship this
might seem to defeat the point of the
Sci-Fi elements or even the story as a
whole but it speaks to the movie's
central theme of love these two have a
special connection and nothing can get
in the way of that it's a hopeful ending
Although seeing the way Clementine and
Joel's relationship plays out makes one
wonder if they're doomed to repeat the
same mistakes should these two really be
together or is the love that was strong
enough to bring them back together also
enough to break their old Dynamic
according to Vanity Fair Kaufman
originally conceived of a darker ending
in which Joel walks away after learning
the triu knowing that gandre and Kaufman
disagreed over whether Joel and
Clementine should end up together
further enhances the uncertainty of what
comes next for this entric
couple by the end of Christopher Nolan's
interstella the audience has fully
versed on what happen at Cooper brand
and Humanity in general however there
are a lot of smaller details that are
left up to our imaginations here are
some of the biggest questions we have
after watching Interstellar it's obvious
that Interstellar takes place in the
future although just how far in in the
future is never clarified we do receive
a few clues that the world of
interstellar isn't tremendously ahead of
our own the character's clothing and
housing or seems to line up with Current
Designs and while the robotics
technology is certainly more advanced
than what we have today it doesn't
appear to be too far beyond where we are
now in order for the Lazarus mission to
have departed 10 years before the start
of the film humans must have made
significant strides in space travel and
cryosleep Technology a decade before the
movie started at the latest and Cooper
looks to be in his late 30s or early 40s
at the start of the movie which means
that his flashbacks to his career as a
NASA pilot must have taken place within
the past couple decades before the movie
began one Theory referencing the book
the science of interstellar extrapolates
that the Wormhole near Saturn was
discovered in 2019 placing the beginning
of the movie around the year 2067
however this is based on supplemental
material and not the film itself while
this seems like a reasonable guess based
on the information presented in
interstellar we have no way of knowing
for sure
one of the most curious throwaway lines
in interstellar happens early on when
Cooper mentions how MRI technology could
have saved his late wife and if we had
any of those left the doctors would have
been able to find the cyst in my wife's
Brain before she died instead afterwards
no further elaboration is given about
why MRIs would have ceased to exist and
it's an odd piece of World building when
you consider that other types of
Technology still appear to be just fine
not only are cars trucks and large
farming equipment still prevalent but
the characters clothing and resources
speak to a manufacturing industry that
is still going strong and while colleges
are now only open to the very top
Echelon of students that's probably
because those students are going into
Highly Educated fields and it's
reasonable to assume medicine would be
among them of course other forms of
technology have been scrapped on purpose
as part of the scapegoating of NASA
explaining how the Apollo missions were
fake to bankrupt the Soviet Union in
response to the blight that wiped out
most of Earth's crops the history books
were Rewritten to teach that the
moonlanding was F and that space
exploration was fule in an effort to
keep Humanity focused on fixing the
problems of Earth not dreaming of the
stars but MRI machines don't seem like
they should have been lumped in with
spaceships in that particular
disinformation campaign since they're
used to diagnose patients here on Earth
could one of the gravitational anomalies
prior to Interstellar have fried all
existing MRI machines simultaneously
perhaps but in that case why not build
new ones Interstellar never offers any
Clarity in what happen to the
life-saving technology so we're left to
guess at the start of interstellar
Earth's crops have been largely
destroyed thanks to a global blight that
eventually wipes out every form of plant
life it encounters Nelson's torching his
whole crop light they're saying it's the
last Harvest for
okra ever corn is one of the only viable
crops that humans have left but even
that will eventually die out leaving
humans with no food source at all
Professor brand mentions at one point
that the blight seems particularly
suited to thriving Earth's largely
nitrogen beta atmosphere spere yet the
film never provides much more detail on
exactly what the blight is we don't know
if it evolved naturally or if humans
somehow caused it through our own
actions the blight affects every last
person on and off of Earth but how it
came to be is left entirely up in the
air before coper heads off into space we
get a couple glimpses of what life is
like in interstellar's Dusty future
version of the United States and it begs
some interesting questions about the
supply chain although the school
principal mentions that most students
will grow up to become Farmers lots of
other Industries must still be up and
running in order to create the world in
which the Coopers live basic utilities
all seem to still exist and cars seem
pretty common which means that the fuel
industry must still be chugging along
most meals are corn-based but the coopas
eat a variety of dishes requiring other
ingredients that they don't seem to grow
on their Farm implying that at least a
modest grocery supply chain is still up
and running their clothes are dusty but
intact so there must be a functional
textile industry as well and perhaps
most bafflingly they still appear to be
professional sports teams with the money
for new custom uniforms it causes us to
wonder exactly how long the list of
viable professions is in the world of
interstellar and why everyone talks as
if the vast majority of people are
farmers when the world they live in
tells a different story even in secret
NASA is still an agency run by the
American government so it's UNS
surprising that Interstellar tells a
pretty America Centric tale but what's
going on in other countries while
Professor brand is spending decades
solving his equation to save the world
surely they're not just sitting around
waiting for the Americans to save the
day but we never get so much as a hint
as to what they are doing Cooper does
mention at one point that there are no
more armies which implies that instead
of the widespread famine prompting War
it has instead incentivized Earth's
population to work on the problem
together he also says that India space
program was disbanded around the same
time as NASA Del missing Patrol went
down same as ours 10 years ago the
teacher at murf School mentions that the
revised version of History claims that
the moonlanding was nothing more than
Soviet propaganda implying that there's
still still no love loss between the two
countries although apparently not enough
to Warrant military intervention by the
end of interstellar Humanity has
successfully escape the dying Planet
we're meant to understand that this
means that all of humanity was saved but
it sure would have been nice to have
some evidence of life outside of the
future United States throughout
Interstellar the characters encounter
various gravitational anomalies both big
and small by the end of the film The
Source of many of these anomalies has
become clear they aren't anomalies at
all but intelligent acts designed to
serve a specific purpose the humans of
the future refer to only as they created
the wormhole in order to give the humans
of the past an escape route from Earth
Cooper himself was responsible for the
various anomalies in his daughter's
childhood bedroom I figured out the
message one word you know what it is
Stay Stay it says stay dad however there
are a number of other anomalies
referenced in interstella that don't
appear to have any clear purpose such as
the one that caused Cooper's instruments
to malfunction when he was working as a
test pilot we started detecting
gravitational anomalies almost 50 years
ago mostly small distortions to our
instruments in the upper atmosphere what
these anomalies were and why they
occurred are never really addressed it
seems reasonable to infer that they CA
the anomalies but for what purpose was
it merely to get Humanity's attention
and this put in motion the sequence of
events leading to the film or did the
past anomalies serve some sort of other
unexplained function that we never learn
about by the time Cooper is finally able
to finally collect and transmit the
quantum data from the black hole
Gargantua to his daughter murf back on
Earth only a few years have passed for
cuber and brand but decades have elapsed
on Earth during that time Professor
brand has been tirelessly working on his
gravity equation although murf later
finds out that he known for years it
wasn't solvable and was merely trying to
give the people on earth a glimmer of
hope until they eventually suffocated to
death in the degrading atmosphere
however for that entire time Professor
brand and MTH are working inside the
massive space station orbiting Saturn
that we see at the end of the film once
Koopa station is in space we see that
its inhabitants are able to use the
space inside it to farm creating food
for the humans who have escaped Earth so
why weren't they using the stations for
that purpose when they were still on
Earth granted they couldn't have used
every inch of real estate for farming if
they were tied down by gravity but it
seems like they should have been able to
figure out a way to use some of it
especially given how much time they had
when the endurance leaves Earth it's
only been 10 years since wolf Edmunds
and the other scientists first departed
on the Lazarus missions but by the time
and finally makes it to the planet where
had set up camp nearly 90 years have
passed and Edmunds has died this implied
that he was killed when a rock slide
destroyed the cryochamber in which he
was hibernating although it's also
possible that he died due to a
malfunction in the chamber itself and
the rock slide happened afterward that
Edmunds didn't survive until brand was
able to reach his Planet isn't really
surprising but what's interesting is the
question of when he died although
Edmunds was only sent to his planet with
2 years worth of resources he could
extend that almost indefinitely with his
cryogenic pod so so when Brandon the
endurance first emerged from the
Wormhole 12 years after Edmunds first
departed only a year or two would have
passed for Edmunds assuming his pod was
still functioning even after brand lost
23 years on the water Planet Edmunds
could have still been alive it's
possible that if Cooper had taken
Brand's suggestion and headed straight
to his Planet they might have arrived in
time to save Edmunds although in that
case cuer might not have gotten the data
that saves the rest of humanity when the
endurance departs on his mission they're
heading to a system in a distant Galaxy
with three potentially habitable planets
based on the data sent back from three
of the astronauts on the Lazarus Mission
however 12 astronauts originally
departed 10 years earlier with a mission
to each explore one of 12 possible weals
they all knew that the chances of their
world being able to support human life
were slim and that if their Planet
wasn't a good candidate for relocation
that they'll be on their own for the
rest of their lives however while it's
implied that none of the other nine
worlds that Lazarus astronauts visited
were viable and that those astronauts
eventually died we don't actually know
that for sure it's POS possible that one
or more of the planets was viable but
something happened to the astronauts or
their equipment before they could send
back the thumbs up that would send NASA
to them it's even possible that one or
more of the astronauts are still
slumbering away in cryosleep not really
living but not truly dead either
throughout Interstellar Humanity
receives help from them mysterious
beings that the scientists of NASA
assume must be benevolent
extraterrestrials however by the end of
the film Cooper realizes that they
aren't aliens at all but actually the
humans of the future who have figured
out a way to exist and to navigate in
five Dimensions this creates a bootstrap
Paradox in which the existence of the
humans of the future depends on them
already existing to help the humans of
the past but that's easy enough to
explain in the world of interstellar
where time may not actually be linear at
all what we don't know is exactly how
far in the future these five-dimensional
humans are or if they even exist in a
specific time at all once murf solves
Professor Bran's gravity equation it
opens up a whole new world for Humanity
not only are they able to escape their
dying Planet but they're able to thrive
in new ways that they never could
unearth perhaps murf's breakthrough is
precisely what lays the groundwork for
these new future humans meaning that
they're not as far ahead of the humans
aboard Cooper station as one might think
then again it could take centuries or
even Millennia for humans to evolve to
that point at the beginning of
interstellar Cooper's two children murf
and Tom function as pretty typical
siblings neither best friends nor mortal
enemies but simply two kids who mostly
get along and occasionally get under
each other's skin all that changes
though when Cooper leaves AB the
endurance spends the next few decades
nursing a grudge against her father
while Tom does his best to remain in
touch even long after Cooper stops
responding during that time Tom marries
and has two children but his oldest dies
a few years later of complications due
to the dust saturated atmosphere murf
meanwhile throws herself into a work
with Professor brand and rarely visits
home but eventually returns to try to
convince Tom to move his family out of
their old farmhouse and underground with
her when Tom refuses murf decides to
trick him throwing him away which she
can essentially kidnap his family she
doesn't actually manage to leave before
Tom returns and by then she's realized
she has what she needs to solve the
gravity equation and save Humanity but
while murf gives her brother a relieved
hug upon his return Tom doesn't look
nearly as ready to bury the hatchet
despite murf's great accomplishment for
Humanity the action she took with her
brother's family significantly overshot
the boundaries he set but we never see
Tom again after that making us wonder if
the end justify the means for him or
whether murf's actions damaged their
relationship permanently after coopa es
from the black hole they drop him off
near Saturn right to where a ranger from
Cooper station is passing by to pick him
up while it's only been a few minutes
for Cooper since he jettisoned himself
from the endurance in order to send
brand onto Edmund's Planet it's been
over 60 years for the people of Earth
due to the time slippage in Gargantua
even if it took a while for murf to
actually Implement a solved equation and
launch the space stations humans have
had decades in which to find a new home
and yet Cooper station and others like
it are still content to just float
around near a Saturn despite never
having received received conclusive data
about the world just on the other side
of the Wormhole we know the Wormhole
still exists since that's how Cooper
returns to brand at the end of the film
as far as NASA knows one of those
planets from the Lazarus Mission could
still be a viable new home world it's
understandable that they wouldn't want
to send an entire station through as a
guinea pig but why not send a few
Rangers after the endurance went silent
It Seems like by the time brand arrived
on everyone's Planet a whole human
Colony could have already been set up
and ready to go and she wouldn't have
had to be alone at all
the final episodes of fan favorite TV
shows tend to be emotional from sadness
to a sense of closure and even to anger
over things not panning out quite as
audiences may have expected in the case
of these shows though the major feeling
most fans got after watching their final
moments was total confusion here are
some TV show endings that required a
little unpacking The
Sopranos perhaps the most perplexing TV
finale of all time The Soprano's final
scene is still nothing short of confound
ing throughout the last season fans
picked apart every episode theorizing
about how the story of mafia boss Tony
Soprano would conclude but chances are
nobody saw this coming in the final
moments the show's anti-hero and his
family are shown sitting at a diner
listening to Journeys Don't Stop
Believing before Tony notices a man
looking around the diner
and the quickfire curtaining was so
abrupt that many viewers thought
something went wrong with their cable
feed and when they realized it wasn't a
technical error they were fuming even
more according to series Creator David
chase the ending was meant to imply that
Tony would always be paranoid and that
endings for guys like him usually come
out of nowhere like this but it's taken
fans years of dissection to draw their
own conclusions about Tony's ultimate
fate and even still not everyone's
convinced it was conclusive it was a
huge let down for what was otherwise a
legendary series Roseanne for eight
seasons Roseanne brought the the
midwestern Blue Collar life to light by
way of the Connor family from their
consistent money troubles to their kids
disappointing decisions the sitcom
series was underscored by some relatable
drama that carried it for nearly a
decade without issue but then in the
ninth and once final season the Connors
came into some serious dough after
winning the lottery and the show went
completely off the rails the last run
quickly turned into some Beverly
Hillbillies reducts that featured Dan
having an affair Darlene delivering a
premature baby and a massive last minute
twist that basically erased it all in
the final moments we find out the whole
series was a book written by Roseanne
but she's taken some creative Liberties
to cope with and Escape her harsh
realities notably Dan hadn't had an
affair because he died from a heart
attack years before and as a result of
that Switcheroo she proceeds to explain
that much of the events seen on the show
never happened like who her kids
actually married the wonky ending was
not well received and with the Rosanne
Revival in route for 2018 we can
probably count on that backtracking to
take another drastic turn as John
Goodman is reprising his role for the
new series as far as we know he's not
expected to return as some zombie no
matter how much the Connor family loveed
their Halloween tricks look you you're
going to need
stitches so chances are the finale will
get swept under the rug alt together by
the time the new series launches I still
think the Bulls of 96 97 would have beat
these guys anytime you can't live in the
past Dan when things are gone they're
gone forever Battlestar Galactica with
Battlestar Galactica the Sci-Fi channel
took the classic 1970 show about space
hippies and turned it into a gritty
story about the last humans trying to
survive in outer space the show featured
humans that were from another galaxy
venturing out into space looking for the
lost human colony of Earth to make a new
home there in the last season they
finally find the Third Rock From the Sun
but it's a nuclear Wasteland and
everyone is dead the confusion sets in
when we see Cara Starbuck thce returned
from the dead under mysterious
circumstances to Usher them into their
new dwelling she'd seemingly passed away
in the prior season so her ill-
explained Revival was a head scratcher
indeed but then things got even more
inexplicable when in the finale she has
shown saying goodbye to Apollo before
disappearing into the wind I am done
here I've completed my journey executive
producer Ron Moore tried to explain that
Starbuck had been brought back to life
by a higher power power to lead humans
to Earth but real life earthlings were
left stunned by the bizarre stunt
Hannibal Brian Fuller's stylish horror
series took the idea of a cliffhanger
literally the show's murderous cannibal
Hannibal Lector and FBI profiler Will
Graham culminate their Twisted series
long game of cat and mouse with a brutal
combat at the edge of a cliff at which
point they both fall off into the sea
and that's it we're left to wonder
whether anyone survived the fall and the
question mark about about that Prospect
is even furthered by the season 3
post-credit scene in it Hannibal's
enabler psychiatrist Bedelia is shown
waiting at a dinner table with two empty
play settings and her own severed leg
ready to be served kind of makes you
hungry for more No Angel when this
spin-off of Buffy the Vampire Slayer
debuted in 1999 it was about vampire
Angel's small Los Angeles private
detective agency by the end of the fifth
season however the show had evolved into
a story of a grand war between Good and
Evil in which Angel and his cohorts were
determined to destroy the wicked circle
of the Black Thorn the final shots of
the series finale show Angel and the
good guys heading into battle against a
massive Army just as the episode ends
ending in the beginning of a battle is
certainly an understandable point of
confusion but co-creator Jos Weeden told
TV gu the final scene of the series
demonstrates the notion that the war
between good and evil is never over
saying the point of the show is that
you're never done no matter who goes
down the fight goes on and so does the
fans quest for a sense of
closure and let's make them
memorable it's been nearly a decade
since the release of Zack Snider's
Sucker Punch to sort through our many
conflicting feelings about this
mind-bending action thriller we're
giving the film another look and
examining all the things we still don't
understand about it but first a word of
warning Major Spoilers are
ahead after accidentally killing her
sister while trying to protect her from
their abusive stepfather a young woman
only known as baby doll ends up in a
mental Asylum from the moment she
arrives she's at the mercy of a corrupt
and vicious orderly named Blue with just
5 days remaining until baby doll is
scheduled to be lobotomized she teams up
with four other inmates to plot a daring
breakout now this is where things start
to get a little tricky as baby doll
Works towards escaping physically she
appears to be escaping her bonds
mentally as well she starts starts
imagining Fantastical worlds in which
she and her crew are powerful Heroes
going on a series of grand Adventures
it's all a bit complicated so let's
break it down step by step Sucker Punch
operates on three levels of reality the
first is the real world which is the
corrupt mental Asylum where it seems
that baby doll and the other patients
are victimized by the staff the second
level is a night club that also
functions as a brothel for its wealthy
clients baby doll imagines that the
Asylum is in fact this dangerous
nightclub run by a violent and
possessive
mobster the third level of reality is
baby doll's totally Fantastical and
heroic world of Adventures which is
always set to modern rock and pop music
we completely understand the Asylum
that's the real world we also basically
understand the fantasy sequences baby
doll imagines a place in which she's
powerful because in the actual World
she's not but it's that second layer of
reality the nightclub and the brothel
that has a is confused it certainly
isn't functioning as escapism for any of
the female characters the imaginary
brothel is no less hostile than the
Asylum just slightly different we can't
really think of a deeper thematic or
artistic motivation behind its inclusion
apart from being an excuse to dress up
all the female characters in Minik
skirts and lingerie this is a joke right
unless we're missing something we can't
figure out what the film would lose if
it cut out the brothel and only had two
levels of reality instead of three
the tone would be the same the trauma
would be the same all that would change
are the costumes and color palette oh
and the fact that the characters
wouldn't be in a brothel each time baby
doll dances in the nightclub reality
she's temporarily transported to a
different Fantastical world full of
enemies and monsters that she must slay
she's faced with everything from giant
Samurai to zombie steampunk soldiers to
Killer Robots the implication is that
these are baby dolls dreams but why
would a young person from the midnight
1900s be dreaming in the tropes of
modern geek culture that would be
crazy however there's a version of this
that could have worked in movies a
character's dreams are a general
reflection in some way of who that
person is director Zack Snyder has
stated an interviews that the comics
Magazine heavy metal was a major
inspiration for Sucker Punch so perhaps
baby doll herself could have also been
established as a comic book fan or even
better she could have been an aspiring
writer or artist who is just a couple
decades ahead of for time dreaming of
fictional worlds that didn't exist yet
for much of the movie it seems as if the
filmmakers treat baby doll much the same
way as her captures do simply as a means
to an end an object that only exists to
fulfill their wishes she isn't really a
person and her inner life doesn't matter
these sequences are rather transparently
just the writer's fantasies and not
hers whenever baby doll and her friends
are fighting enemies in a fantasy
sequence they're also dealing with a
problem in the nightclub reality however
most of the time the actions they're
performing within a fantasy seem to have
little to do with the corresponding
goals they're trying to achieve outside
of it do the specifics of these
fantasies actually matter to the real
world or are they just supposed to look
really cool for instance in one sequence
baby doll is distracting a wealthy man
by dancing while another woman Amber
steals a lighter from his jacket in the
fantasy however Amber is providing air
cover from a plane so that baby doll can
sneak up on a baby dragon and steal a
pair of magic crystals the action is a
complete inversion of what's actually
happening in the nightclub level of
reality for no apparent reason and it
makes it difficult to get emotionally
invested in the dragon slaying scene one
notable exception to this lack of
cohesion occurs when the women are
trying to steal a kitchen knife when
they fail and Rocket gets stabbed by the
cook in the nightclub reality we cut
back to the fantasy world where rocket
heroically sacrifices herself to save
her friends it's one of the stronger
moments in the film primar apparently
because the specifics of the fantasy
sequences actually mean something a
popular fan theory about Sucker Punch is
that baby doll isn't actually the point
of view character in truth the entire
story is being told in past tense by
sweet pea the only woman who actually
escaped some take this Theory even
further asserting that baby doll herself
never existed and she's an alternate
Persona that sweet PE invented for
herself a Flawless superhero that sweet
PE pretended to be so she could gather
the strength to break free of the asylum
this was never my
story it's
yours now don't screw it up
okay so possibly sweet PE invented the
character of baby doll because even if
she couldn't personally imagine slaying
the dragons in her own life she could
imagine another person a hero who could
lie to yourself if you must tell
yourself that you have superpowers and
there's no obstacle you can't overcome
or to put it another way you have all
the weapons you need now fight after the
Cru plann to escape fails things don't
end well for most of them rocket is
killed by the cook then Blondie and
Amber are executed by Blue in the
dressing room of the nightclub in the
end only Sweet Pea is able to survive
and Escape but remember all of this is
only happening in the imaginary world of
the nightclub and not the real world of
the Asylum we do get a few brief scenes
in the Asylum after those tragedies but
rocket Amber and blonde are nowhere to
be seen were they actually killed if you
die in the nightclub do you die in real
life the only hints that we get are
courtesy of Dr Gorski when she offers a
brief account of baby doll's eventful 5
days in the Asylum she stabbed in
orderly started a fire and and helped
another patient to
escape however she doesn't say anything
about an orderly named Blue openly
executing two other patients in front of
her additionally given that blue is
eventually arrested for authorizing
medical procedures in gorsky's name
without her permission you'd imagine
that openly murdering patients would be
much bigger news it makes sense if blue
is a powerful and violent mobster and
gorski's working for him but it doesn't
make sense at all if he's a mere orderly
and she's a doctor who presumably
outranks him however things went down in
the real version of baby doll's
attempted Escape it was probably quite
different and whether or not rocket
Blondie and Amber died in real life
that's just one of the many things we'll
never know there's little in Sucker
Punch that's as confusing as the
mysterious wise man who appears in baby
doll's fantasy battle sequences this
enigmatic figure typically offers baby
doll in her team advice in the form of
trit bumper sticker truisms for those
who fight for life has a flavor the
sheltered will never
know even more puzzling these words of
wisdom consistently have no discernable
relevance to the crew's current
situation nor do they relate to the
movie's deeper themes so why is this
character in the film we get an answer
sort of in the final scene as sweet pea
is boarding the bus that will take her
to Freedom some police officers start
asking her questions suspecting that
she's an escap mental patient
fortunately the bus driver steps in and
convinces them to leave her alone this
character is played by Scott Glenn who
also portrayed the wise man one
potential interpretation makes sense if
as we mentioned earlier Sweet Pea has
been the protagonist all along and she's
telling her story in the past tense
since all these fantasies are really
hers perhaps she chose to retroactively
cast this man who saved her on the bus
as a mentor figure throughout her entire
story if so we can't help but wonder why
she wouldn't cast Gorski in that role
instead she was helping all the women
stay alive the entire time and not just
at the very last minute I teach them to
survive
you sucker punch definitely has some
problematic moments and most have to do
with how the film treats its female
characters the issue isn't that it's
about abuse plenty of films about
exploitation aren't themselves
exploitative consider Mad Max Fury Road
just like Sucker Punch the plot centers
on women who are attempting to free
themselves from a terrible situation
their roads to Freedom are similarly
long and dangerous and not all of them
make it what Fury Road understands
however is that even though characters
within the film May treat women as if
they're objects the film itself should
always treat them like people the main
female characters get clearly defined
personalities wants and conflicting
philosophies though sucker Punch's heart
may be in a similar place it falls short
of the mark in its execution the film's
female heroes are more or less
interchangeable Barbie dolls with
minimal dialogue and indistinct
personalities they exist only to be
stared at tortured and eventually killed
for shock value contrast this with how
the movie treats the primary abuser blue
he's perhaps the most complex
three-dimensional character in the film
and his numerous lengthy monologues mean
that he is easily twice as much dialogue
as any woman this sadly proves that
sucker punch can make a character
interesting when it cares about them it
just didn't care enough about its female
Heroes to do this sucker punch is often
accused of being a shallow and
exploitative film that only exists as an
excuse to show women in miniskirts
fighting in slow motion for all the
harsh things we've said about the film
so far are we don't think that's
entirely Fair the film is clearly trying
to make some sort of deeper point so
let's give it the benefit of the doubt
and try to figure out what the
filmmakers might be trying to say within
the context of the fantasy sequences
Sucker Punch mimics the tropes of
Senseless and seductive action films
this practice of filming women in an
objectifying way to bring pleasure to
the viewer is often referred to as the
male gaze a term coined by film theorist
Laura mulv Sucker Punch however might be
attempting to challenge this paradigm
through additional layers of reality the
Asylum and the nightclub the film
equates The objectification of women in
film with the dehumanization they
experience in real life which could be
interpreted as a condemnation of both
forms of
exploitation all of this culminates in
the scene of baby doll's labotomy when
she's stabbed in the eye so is the
viewer the male gaze is penetrated our
happy ending denied we think we're
getting a fun Escapist fantasy and
instead the ending of the film hits us
like well a sucker
punch so what's the final verdict is
Sucker Punch pure exploitation or a
statement about it in truth it's sort of
both but more than anything it's just
confused the film takes a stab at a
feminist message but whatever it's
trying to say gets lost in a web of
shallow characters dead end plot threads
and inexplicable narrative choices have
you just ever wanted to just take
something
back that being said for all the film's
faults a lack of ambition is is not one
of them there were plenty of bigger than
life action scenes stunning imagery and
genuinely outrageous Concepts we'd much
rather that filmmakers take big swings
like this one even if they miss and fall
down in spectacular
fashion
well so much for that little
experiment whether it's a zombie movie
with the heart of a romance or look at
the Terrors of being a parent these
horror flicks are aren't properly
understood by many of the people who
watch them based on the novel by Jeff
vmir Alex Garland's Annihilation has one
of the most confusing and
thought-provoking movie endings of the
last decade biologist Lena takes a
journey into the unknown after her
husband Cain returns from a three-year
disappearance with some rather strange
changes she and a team of women enter
the mysterious meteor Fallout Zone known
as the Shimmer to try and find out what
exactly happened to Kane while he and
his team more inside if you're looking
for a straightforward answer to this
setup Annihilation won't exactly deliver
instead Annihilation skirts the fine
line between horror and sci-fi as Lena
and her crew discover the DNA mixing
properties of the alien presence when
Lena arrives at the Lighthouse at the
center of the Shimmer she has an
encounter that leaves her a changed
woman quite literally the ending of
annihilation has sparked a lot of debate
some believe it to be a metaphor
concerning death or disease but Garland
has said that has to do with
self-destruction isn't self-destruction
coded into US programmed into each cell
whatever the meaning it's an ending
that's nearly impossible to forget
considered by many to be director Dario
argento's magnum opus susperia takes on
the occult in a manner that has inspired
countless copycats since the film's 1977
release susperia is a visual spectacle
first and foremost and that's far from a
Bad Thing tolden Argento signature Grand
guol style which relies more on
Ultraviolence and brooding tone than
telling one cohesive story susperia
follows dancer Susie bny into Germany as
she joins the prestigious T Dance
Academy to perfect her ballet abilities
it's impossible not to be drawn into
Susie's surreal new world as strange
things begin happening around her she
gets sick the school suffers a maggot
infestation and the blind pianist is
killed by his own dog so it's no real
shock when Susie discovers that this
illustrious dance school once was and
still is the witch's coven while this is
the first entry into aro's three
mother's Trilogy Suspiria is a
delightfully cryptic watch that'll stick
with you long after the credits roll at
23 years old director Don karelli kicked
off his filmmaking career with a head
scratcher that's equally imaginative and
horrific fantasm follows a boy named
Mike who witnesses a body being stolen
from the local Cemetery this leads Mike
and his brother jod on an investigative
mission to check out the mausoleum where
they happen upon an evil mortician
better known as the Tolman who has the
power to reanimate corpses this
discovery sends The Tall Man on a
mission to capture Mike and jod birthing
his iconic horror movie
[Music]
catchphrase
boy of course you can't forget about the
murderous silver ball that flies into
people's skulls with the sole purpose of
retrieving brain meat for the late '70s
fantasm was definitely a horror film
that left audiences wanting more the
third act falls apart a bit leaving
audiences wanting to know exactly why
the tall man is doing what he's doing
thankfully karelli returned to the world
in characters he created 9 years later
with 1988's fantasm 2 kicking off a
quirky and gory little franchise loved
by many DieHard horror fans when it
comes to style over substance Beyond the
Black rainbow is a poster trial for the
phrase Panos Kato's 2010 debut is chalk
full of trippy visuals and syn filled
soundscapes but when it comes to story
there's not much of one at all Elena is
a mute girl with psychic powers kept a
prisoner in an institution by a crazy
doctor who loves watching her meltdown
on his many windows and monitors of
course once she's figured out how to
harness her abilities she escapes in a
mindbending extended sequence overall
The Narrative of Beyond the Black
rainbow boils down the conflict between
doctor and patient using its surreal
futuristic looking hospital as a unique
backdrop as surreal as the imagery is
though nailing down an actual plot
becomes quite difficult when pressed
cosm's stylistic Slow Burn was
undoubtedly meant to appeal to audiences
on a more subconscious level when
viewing Beyond the Black rainbow with
those expectations in mind one may
finish viewing the movie in an altered
mindset but if you're looking for a
clear-cut first second and third act it
might be best to look else word after
the breakout success of Drive many
anticipated Danish filmmaker Nicholas
winning refen to go on to make some of
the next decades action Classics instead
refen followed up the stylish Thriller
with two much more baffling films the
second of which was the L Fanning Le
fashion horror fck the neon demon
Fanning plays Jesse a young fashion
model who has recently moved to Los
Angeles there she meets models Gigi and
Sarah and their makeup artist Ruby who
immediately take an interest in her as
Jesse gets closer and deeper she finds
something extremely dark hiding beneath
the beautiful facade what's wrong with
that
anyway women would kill to look like
this as weird as things already were the
ending really takes a turn when Jesse
finds herself the victim of her new
peers cannibalistic impulses on the
surface the twist in the neon demon
serves as a metaphor for the pain you
face if you're a model or or actress the
system will change your values and then
Eat You Alive however there's also a
deeper layer here Gigi's body rejects
Jesse's organs which symbolizes how she
had become rotten or impure in the
process of entrapping and capturing
their prey these siren-like Predators
have ruined what made Jesse desirable in
the first place long before Peter
Jackson made a name for himself with the
Lord of the Rings movies he brought
1992's bonkers horror goodie Dead Alive
originally titled brain dead to the
world Dead Alive is a simple New Zealand
Love Story buried deep inside a zany
Undead apocalypse hapless hero Lionel
costro struggles to keep his Suburban
family together after a disease from a
Sumatran rat monkey starts to turn
normal people into flesh eating zombies
of course things don't go according to
plan meaning it's not long before he has
to take things into his own hands
shedding tons of zombie blood along the
way to save pakita his one true love you
can easily bypass any confusion by
looking at Dead Alive as a story of love
and Redemption but there's a whole lot
of family drama included in Jackson's
tale that gives the story some weird
uncomfortable layers the Gory
combination of humor and horror puts
this gross out flick in a category all
its own Stephen King may have gone on
record many times regarding his disdain
for Stanley Kubrick's 1980 adaptation of
his classic story of The Shining but the
jack Nicholson and Shelley Deval
starring film is a classic for good
reason intense performances disturbing
imagery Epic camera work and twist
Galore make this movie A one-of-a-kind
Masterpiece it's inspired so many wild
theories that it'll make your head spin
on the surface King's tale explores the
story of a fractured family on a descent
into madness Jack Torrance and his son
Danny share telepathic abilities Danny's
aware of it but Jack is not that brings
things to a chaotic and bloody crescend
as the family takes rote in the haunted
Overlook Hotel in the dead of winter as
a horrific ghost story The Shining works
wonders but if you go deeper into the
theories about the film many of which
are outlined in the documentary room 237
you'll start seeing odd narrative layers
you may not have recognized before it's
impossible to watch The Shining without
having some kind of lingering
distressing question I'm very
confused I just made a CH the we thing
is over Darren aronowski isn't the type
of director to Pander to the box office
he makes the movies he wants to make and
doesn't seem to care what audiences
think that's definitely a good thing
because audiences didn't really care for
mother to the point that it became one
of only a few movies to earn the lowest
possible Cinema score grade of f what
exactly is this movie about and why did
so many people hate it the latter
question is much easier to answer
Jennifer Lawrence and Javier Bardem
Stars a married couple looking to
rebuild their lives after a tragic fire
as Lawrence attempts to resurrect the
home from the ground up odd events begin
to occur that seem to link her own
health with that of the house after an
unexpected encounter with a family of
strangers Lawrence becomes pregnant with
bardam's child inspiring him to write a
poem the poem resonates with the people
a bit too much soon the house has turned
into a battlefield featuring cult
members looters and Riot police and by
the end nothing is left it's a visual
Onslaught that's anxiety inducing deeply
upsetting and downright confusing is
Jennifer Lawrence's character the symbol
of Mother Nature is bm's poet really a
look at the power of humanity in
relation to Earth's slow destruction
there's a lot to unpack here for sure
but in a world of formulaic films mother
is certainly unique For Better Or Force
after the breakout success of Jordan
peele's get out horror fans knew to
expect layers of metaphor and social
commentary from the director's next
venture what they didn't expect was that
us peele's second feature outing would
be even denser in its construction while
it starts off as a home invasion movie
about a black family being invaded by a
family of doppelgangers known as the
tethered us slowly unravels its layers
of meaning on a surface level us is
relatively easy to understand with a
final twist that changes everything you
thought you knew about the Wilson family
according to Adelaide Wilson's
doppelganger red the tether were
developed in a failed government
experiment and sealed underground for
Generations red was able to convince the
other Tethered to rise to the surface
world and take down their lookalikes and
for a shocking reason of course the true
message of the film ended up going over
a lot of people's heads beneath the
rabbit eating and scissor stabbing us is
actually a metaphor about inequality and
class struggle as the tether joined
their Hands Across America they unite
forces in a way that our petty human
squabbles would never allow us to do
every David Lynch movie is confusing and
to some extent every David Lynch movie
is a horror movie that's why picking
just one to represent his entire
filmography is a nearly impossible
Choice while malland Drive Inland Empire
and Lost Highway could all fit on this
list it's Lynch's debut feature that
still missed IES and puzzles viewers
after over 45 years eraser head is a
surrealist black and white film that
investigates the horrors of domestic
life in The Most Extreme Ways possible
Henry Spencer lives in a Suburban
industrial Wasteland one day he's
informed that his girlfriend has had a
child but what they've created is
anything but human when she hysterically
leaves him to take care of the child for
what feels like an endless amount of
time Spencer brings us into his
hallucinator World filled with
metaphorical visions and characters
eraser head ends with Spencer killing
the creature to put it out of its misery
and meeting his own strange fate but
taking these events at face value is the
wrong way to look at this deeply
metaphorical film the main theme eraser
head reinforces is the anxiety of
Parenthood Lynch whose daughter was 9
years old when the film was released
seemingly channeled his worries into one
of the most daringly cryptic films of
the '70s some of the weirder parts of
the movie will never be explained and
that's just the way the director likes
it believe it or not a racer head is my
most spiritual film mhm why we elaborate
on that no I won't if you're looking to
dip your toes into the world of Japanese
experimental horror then 1977's house is
an ideal First Step this Japanese horror
movie from 1977 operates almost entirely
in dream logic Mak for 88 of the most
entertaining and confounding minutes
ever put to film in house a school girl
named gorgeous takes six friends to her
aunt's rural home for summer vacation
once they arrive the house reveals
itself to be a wacky Haunted Mansion
that starts eating the girls alive one
girl is eaten by piano fingers first
another is beaten up by flying
mattresses those aren't even the
strangest things to happen in this house
there's plenty of crazy occurrences
involved Kung Fu watermelon and a cute
yet Sinister cat while it's easy to
enjoy house for its visual Splendor and
absurdity there's some real depth to its
content as well director nobiko obashi
who was born in Hiroshima in 1938 and
lost his childhood friends to the atomic
bomb would go on to make very explicit
anti-war movies like hanagatami in his
late career these themes of the ways War
can haunt both people and anent entire
nation are present in the subtext of
this 1977 surrealist nightmare Lucas
guadagnino susperia is a completely
different movie than argento's 1977
original both tonally and thematically
while the basic plot Remains the Same
Susie banan attends a dance school in
West Berlin in 1977 guadino weaves a
tale that is historical meaning on top
of the already confusing story of The
Surreal original there's a number of
things the Remake has that the original
doesn't like h a Swinton in three roles
a grotesque contortion sequence and an
extra 50 minutes to name a few the
biggest difference though involves an
entirely new side plot that changes the
movie's ending in a massive way while
Susie still ultimately discovers the
true identity of mother Marcos and the
coven of witches much attention is paid
to the investigations of one Dr Joseph
clemer this might seem to distract from
the horror and tension of the 2018
susperia but the addition of this
character ties is The Surreal story to
Real History comp's conflict revolves
around losing his wife in World War II
and the guilt and grief he feels are a
metaphor for living in that time period
in Germany at the end of saperia Susie
visits clur on his deathbed and she
grants him what he's been searching for
the truth about his wife there's a
touching tragic story at the heart of
this horrific historical epic she was
cold when she
died
but she wasn't
afraid war is Hell quite literally if
you're Jacob's singer in his case seen
in 1990s Jacob's Ladder it's the Vietnam
War which haunts his dreams as he tries
to live a relatively quieter life as
opposed to him these nightmares ranging
from cryptic flashbacks to faceless
demons refuse to allow him to move on
Jacob's Ladder can be difficult to
follow at times but there's never any
question that the monsters Jacob sees
symbolize the post-traumatic stress
disorder that so many soldiers bring
home with them if they return home at
all Jacob's earlier Life as a married
father of three is clouded over by the
stain of his time on the me Kong Delta
but the reality of his present may be
the most terrifying thing of all what
begins as a psychological Thriller
steeped heavily in demonic symbolism
quickly turns into an allegory of Heaven
hell and the place troubled Souls can
get stuck in between what's real and
what is it does it even matter you'll
probably have to watch it through a few
times to find out C for Smith's triangle
is an odd movie for sure one that feels
like it may have worked better as an
episode of the xfiles this 2009 film
centers on Jess a troubled mother who
goes on a yacht trip with a group of
friends from the very beginning she's
under the impression that something's
wrong after a storm hits the boat her
crew finds rescue in a passing ocean
liner and yet that for booting feeling
only gets worse for Jess that's for good
reason there's a killer on the boat that
reveal is the first in a long line of
twists that throws just face to face
with none other than herself while
triangle relies heavily on the Trope of
a horror film time loop it's intriguing
and entertaining to watch Jess attempt
to murder every version of herself and
her friends she comes across with the
goal of breaking the cycle but no matter
how hard she tries she never quite
manages to Break Free the ending of
triangle may not provide audiences with
the clear-cut closure they expected or
hoped for but it's a thought-provoking
one that will have you thinking about
the hidden impact of everyday behaviors
Christian Bale is Unforgettable as
Patrick baitman the psychopathic yepy at
the Heart of Mary haren's adaptation of
the Brett eston Ellis novel bitman lives
a privileged life in 1980s Manhattan
privileged enough that he routinely gets
away with the murder of sex workers and
colleagues by the end of American Psycho
it seems like baitman is a full-blown
serial killer driven to Madness by the
lack of consequences for his actions or
is he the infamous monologue that wraps
up the film calls the real ity of every
earlier scene into question My
Punishment continues to elude me and I
gain no deeper knowledge of myself the
confusing ending of American Psycho left
audiences stumped but it all boils down
to one factor the unreliable narrator on
one hand there is the interpretation
that baitman is powerful enough that he
can get away with whatever he pleases
and his associates will cover for him as
horrifying as that might be the darker
ending is that baitman can no longer
tell the difference between his
psychotic fantasies and re ities
ultimately it's left ambiguous as to how
many of the killings in American Psycho
actually happened and how much of it was
in bait's
head featuring plots made up as they
went along and Cliffhangers left forever
unresolved these sci-fi shows have left
some fans scratching their heads for
decades Netflix's altered carbon ran for
two seasons with two different lead
Stars Anthony Mackey and Joel kinaman
playing the same character and that's
the least befuddling part about it a
cyberpunk Punk Thriller altered carbon
is set in a future where people can
receive new bodies and swap Minds much
of the confusion for this show comes
simply from its complex fictional
Universe where unusual political and
social structures play key roles new
ideas are often given awkward slang
terms that can be tough to pick up
factions like the envoy and the
priorians have motives and agendas that
aren't always easily defined characters
receiving new bodies or sleeves thanks
to their stack a dis that contains their
memories and Consciousness is just the
tip of the iceberg but moving past some
already bewildering terminology and
intricate World building the series is
also a murder mystery that's just as
compelling and confusing as anything
you'll find this site of True Detective
like many on this list altered carbon is
a strange journey through a bizarre
sci-fi world that requires some focus
and thought to follow leaving plenty of
audiences
perplexed arguably one of the most
disappointing sci-fi series of the past
20 years Under the Dome was based on an
acclaimed Steven King kn novel and
showed incredible promise in its first
season telling the story of a small town
that suddenly finds itself encased in an
invisible Dome and cut off from the
outside world the initial batch of
stories amounts to a successful mystery
and a suspenseful Thriller but trying to
turn a one-off novel into a multi-season
show proved problematic as the creators
introduced many wildly different
elements that seem to come out of
nowhere to extend the story this
includes a war among the town's people
an alliance with aliens and even an
episode that introduces an alternate
reality suddenly what had initially
hooked audiences as a compelling but
relatively straightforward mystery and
character drama devolved into baffling
sci-fi schlock to make matters worse
audiences were left dumbfounded as new
story lines came and went with no
explanation as a result ratings fell and
by the time the show was cancelled there
were too many unanswered questions to
wrap up the show in any kind of
satisfying way but despite all the
unresolved plot lines the ending of the
show still tries to shove in a few more
in the last episode a decade later Under
the Dome is sadly remembered as a
frustrating sci-fi Adventure that makes
little sense in 1978 Battlestar
Galactica mixed the fast-paced Sci-Fi
adventure of Star Wars with the wild
theories of so-called ancient astronauts
it only lasted a year but garnered a
cult following that led to a
long-awaited Revival in 2004 the newer
series greatly expands on the mythology
of the show but for some the added
complexity just makes it more of a
puzzle in this beloved series a race of
sentient robots known as the syons
decimates a thriving civilization whose
survivors flee to the fabled lost world
called Earth The Twist some of the human
characters are secretly robots in
Disguise which was enough to bewilder
plenty of viewers as the show tried to
write around its own
redcon where
silence and we have been from the
start the importance of a certain Bob
Dylan song also made little sense even
when they tried to explain it as some
kind of Prophecy but when you learn that
series Creator Ron Moore has admitted
that the syons had no overarching plans
the confusing nature of the show's plot
starts to make more sense of course the
most downright frustrating aspect of the
series might be its shoehorned religious
ideas of Destiny and Faith which often
feel like exercises in Hollow symbolism
in the final episode a major character
is implied to have been a Heavenly Angel
all along and an attempt to hastily
resolve a series long riddle suggests
everything was just God's doing for a
show whose initial appeal was its
grounded gritty realism it still went on
to confuse plenty of Hardcore sci-fi
fans the epitome of serialized stories
that were sort of made up as they went
along lost starts as a plane crash
Survivor character drama but before the
end of the pilot episode the series
becomes a captivating Supernatural
mystery as new Sinister forces are
revealed on the island it killed
them he
liard it kill them all by the end of its
run the story includes time travel
alternate realities and even some
religious symbolism for the most part
though the addition of the more
Fantastical elements works it's just
that there's so much going on that it
becomes overly complicated and as a
result fans have been left puzzled for
years while some audiences were more
than confused by much of the show's
story those with a Keen Eye were able to
follow along but with so much to keep
track of it often feels like much of the
larger philosophical issues at play are
left to languish the show's focus on
fate and Free Will kind of Fizzles out
and some plot points and characters that
are implied to have deeper meanings are
pretty much dropped alt together a lot
of this can be chocked up to the writers
acknowledging that they had no idea
where they were going with the story or
they kind of had an idea but had to
change it to keep Network Executives
happy not that it's any consolation to
confused viewers the Sci-Fi conspiracy
Thriller Mr Robot Stars Ramy mik as
cyber security engineer ER and hacker
Elliot Alderson who was enlisted by an
enigmatic figure called Mr Robot to Aid
in his activist causes set in the world
of intricate and complex conspiracies
involving monolithic corporations
faceless governments and shadowy agents
the Web of Lies and back alley deals in
this fictionalized New York City gets
tricky to follow but to add an extra
level of confusion Alderson suffers from
serious anxiety depression and multiple
personalities meaning he can often be an
unreliable narrator to emphasize
alderson's troubled mental state the
show is often intentionally confusing
even the show's most passionate fans
have commented that serious attention is
required to fully grasp the story and
connect every dot major Revelations as
early as season 1 proved mind-boggling
to many viewers While others insisted
that all will be explained by the series
finale but no matter how many times some
fans watch it through there's just so
much densely plotted action on top of
confusing themes that it sometimes feels
like Mr Robot is more trouble than it's
worth even even those critical of the
show have acknowledged the quality of
its writing acting and directing so if
you're willing to put in the work to
understand Mr Robot you'll be handsomely
rewarded running three seasons the
Netflix series dark revolves around a
child kidnapping that reveals an
elaborate scheme by Sinister forces that
stretches back decades between its
convoluted time travel plot and
examination of The Human Condition dark
was called mentally exhausting by Paul
tasi of Forbes Magazine and for good
reason as we're still struggling to
figure everything out years later even
when binged as many did in 2020 when the
series was coming to a close and
millions were trapped inside dark proves
elusive to understand the series
explores time travel in a way that few
others have and forces you down a maze
of ancestry that can be very challenging
to keep track of unless you've printed
out a family tree we meet characters
when they're young and old we meet their
forebears their descendants and
sometimes the ways in which they are
related isn't always so obvious but
that's hardly the only challenge as we
also discover much of the series is set
in Divergent timelines adding a whole
other layer of complexity the series
never lets up either it continues
introducing new and confusing elements
right up until the end giving you no
time to get acclimated to changes and
fluctuations in time and
dimension like a turbocharged X Files
Fringe follows an FBI agent thrown into
the world of the bizaar this series also
deals with more than just aliens in the
Paranormal though in fact by the end of
the Show's first season it has
introduced an entire parallel Earth in
an alternate timeline that is seemingly
at war with our own with multiple
versions of the same characters each
with hidden agendas things only get more
complicated some viewers had trouble
figuring out how things are connected
who is doing what and why then there's
the war between strange visitors from an
alternate future whose own motives seem
to shift from season to season the
problem with this one however might be
the opposite of lost as Fringe seems to
have been planned a little too well at
times the show does a good job of
dropping ing hints about future story
lines but they are often buried a bit
too deep I realize whoever you are that
this must seem very complicated it is
extremely the series may have bitten off
a little more than it could Chew in
season 4 where both realities merge and
still makes for a confusing viewing
experience today meanwhile stories that
push the envelope with intentional
misdirects only serve to further muddy
the waters with a vast and intricate
mythology that can be hard to understand
there are still plenty of questions left
unanswered on Fringe we've seen shows
that are confusing because of intricate
webs of plot and stories that were
written on the Fly and are filled with
plot holes but the OA is something else
entirely a series that is baffling but
might have been comprehensible were it
not unceremoniously canceled before it
could resolve its biggest questions a
series that ends on one of the most
jaw-dropping twists in TV memory it begs
for a follow-up season that never came
the OA Stars Britt Marling as a young
blind woman who has been missing for 7
years but pops up with a new name and
her vision restored she speaks only to a
small group of allies and reveals that
more missing persons can be saved
through a strange dimensional portal
that serves as a Gateway between
multiple Realms but if that sounds
strange wait until you get to the more
magical and mystical parts of the show
including characters who suddenly
manifest Supernatural Powers this
includes one young woman who can
communicate across realities a psychic
nightclub octopus a shadowy Mystic with
a mysterious past robots and a Quantum
Leap style Body transfer that allows
characters to inhabit their own selves
in other realities think you're confused
after that brief description wait until
you watch it just don't expect to get
any answers as we're still trying to
figure it out even knowing we will never
get a
resolution decades before every other
entry on this list the British sci-fi
mystery thriller The Prisoner was well
known for its mystifying story and
mind-bending visuals due to the
technological limitations of the era
it's remembered more for sheer weird
weirdness rather than special effects
making the prisoner a spiritual
precursor to the likes of Twin Peaks
what's it all
about sit down and I'll tell you the
series starred Patrick mcguan as a
secret agent who resigns from his post
only to be abducted and held captive on
a strange Island where nothing is as it
seems beyond its odd nature The Prisoner
became a groundbreaking Landmark series
that influenced multiple genres but
despite its Legacy as arguably one of
the greatest singles season TV shows of
all time it's also one of the most
confusing ever produced mean's
intelligence agent is only ever called
number six while his captors attempt to
break his will week after week for some
nebulous purpose meanwhile strange sites
like giant balloons that can
incapacitate people as quaint as they
might seem to audiences today were
unlike anything anyone had seen at the
time but beyond its unusual style the
story is less than literal playing out
largely in metaphor and allegory with
every prop and plot beat seemingly
hiding some kind of deeper meaning and
significance a series meant to be
experienced and pondered the story had
little in the way of a concrete
conclusion and fans have debated its
meaning for nearly 60
years it's all fun in games until a few
animated rabbits give the kids
Everlasting Trauma from allegorical
genocide to Doodles that would make your
mom blush these cartoons are anything
but your typical Saturday morning Fair
it wasn't too long ago when the Tim
Burton produced computer animated film 9
hit theaters to a resoundingly lukewarm
reception this was a movie that had a
lot going for it before release
including a star studded voice cast and
a seemingly interesting post-apocalyptic
premise it featured the talent of
performers like John C Riley Jennifer
Connelly Christopher Plumber crisen
Glover and Martin landow in starring
roles as creepy little robot dolls
reanimated in a post-apocalypse nine is
centered around around a doll named nine
who must fight against an evil
artificial intelligence that has
destroyed all life on Earth while the
movie had interesting Concepts and ideas
it failed to present them in a coherent
way especially in a way that kids could
understand the story focused on nine
self-conscious ragd dolls called Stitch
punks which contain different aspects of
their Creator's soul that is why I am
making each of
you you all that's left of humanity nine
him self is based on their Creator's
inherent humanity and functions as the
heart of the team other Stitch punks
have traits like healing Fighting Fear
creativity and arrogance which are all
meant to work together in unison while
this may seem interesting on the surface
nine struggles to explain these complex
ideas in an engaging way when it comes
to really weird experimental animated
films it doesn't get more iconic than
Renee laloo's Fantastic Planet this 19
73 piece of Science Fiction was a unique
co-production between French and
Czechoslovakian filmmakers centered
around humans in the far future living
on a planet controlled by gigantic blue
humanoids humans in this world are
treated as pets or pests and the plot
mainly focuses on the relationship
between the alien TAA and a human child
named T who is taken in as a pet
Fantastic Planet is a gorgeous strange
and appropriately fantastic film that
nonetheless confuses many audiences
thanks to its deeper subtext the entire
movie is an allegorical story
representing social issues like animal
rights abuse racism and human rights in
general much of this can be lost on
viewers who don't fully understand the
connection between the mesmerizing
visuals of Fantastic Planet and their
connection to these deeper themes it
certainly doesn't help that the English
language dub of the film completely
altered parts of the dialogue story in
an attempt to make it more kid-friendly
so if you give Fantastic Planet a try
make sure to watch it in the original
French
release yes somebody actually made an
animated musical comedy about the
Titanic sinking cilo tti's Titanic the
legend goes on is an Italian reimagining
of this actual historical event with the
addition of creative Liberties like
talking animals and musical numbers
obviously spinning off the success ESS
of James Cameron's 1997 Blockbuster
Titanic this movie baffled the minds of
anyone who watched it because of how
unbelievably bad it was unlike its
cinematic predecessor Titanic the legend
goes on has little regard for the actual
story of the Titanic and instead adds
things you typically see in a standard
children's animated film the story is
focused on the budding relationship
between a third class passenger named
Angelica and an Upper Crust rich man
named William which Probably sounds
familiar what's really confusing is the
addition of multiple talking animals
ripped straight from a different movie
this Titanic has gone on to be
considered one of the worst animated
movies of all time by both critics and
audiences alike Christopher Campbell of
indiewire Put It Best in his piece 100
Years of terrible Titanic exploitations
in film TV and slides by describing the
film as so terribly written and drawn
that it's offensive to the Titanic's
memory heavy metal is one of the wildest
movies of the 1980s featuring a mix of
intense sci-fi visuals and a hardcore
Rock soundtrack that still slaps to this
day directed by Gerald potterton and
produced by comedy Legend Ivan wman this
movie is best known for its gratuitous
content rather than its narrative
cohesion some of the iconic bands to
have their music featured in the film
include Blue Oyster Cult Black Sabbath
dvo Journey and Cheap Trick what makes
heavy metal so confusing isn't that it's
a bad movie it's that the film is a
series of mostly unrelated Vettes strung
together into a disjointed anthology of
sex violence and Rock and Roll come on
baby let's see what's under
[Music]
there the only thing connecting all the
different segments of heavy metal is a
vague unifying concept of the sum of all
evils being present these days the film
is more famous for being parodied by
South Park in the season 12 episode
major boobage which makes much more
sense than the movie since it's all just
a drug induced hallucinogenic trip that
Kenny endures Richard linklater's 2001
film Waking Life Chronicles a man
stumbling his way through multiple
unrelated realities in a Fugue State
what makes this movie so unique is its
style of Animation rotoscoping in which
animators basic basically Trace every
film frame of a liveaction sequence as a
cartoon while rotoscoping has become
more popular in recent years at the time
this was a wholly unusual way of making
a movie Waking Life is unabashedly an
experimental film without any kind of
cohesive storyline for audiences to
latch onto it follows in the footsteps
of Link later's previous film Slacker by
Meandering from scene to scene and
character to character without any
connections between them Waking Life
also hinges on complicated and
pretentious philosophical themes which
are constantly being discussed by the
characters as the film progresses we are
the authors of ourselves co-authoring a
gigantic Doki novel starring clowns
although the film has a notable critical
Acclaim within 80% on Rotten Tomatoes it
nonetheless can be an inscrutable and
confusing film for audiences who enjoy a
comprehensible plot 1988's Who Framed
Roger Rabbit proved to the world that
combining live action with animations
can work perfectly in a mainstream
Hollywood movie on the other hand 1992's
cool world equally proved that it can
totally backfire when your movie just
isn't very good Ralph vy's attempt to
piggyback off the success of Roberts zc'
more popular film featured a young Brad
Pitt as a Noir detective for the cartoon
landscape of cool world while Cool
World's animation is certainly
impressive its ability to combine
cartoons and liveaction elements is not
but the film's biggest failure is that
its story is borderline incomprehensible
critics at the time noted just how hard
it was to enjoy a movie that's
impossible to follow in his 1992 review
for the Los Angeles Times Peter Rainer
asserted that the plot makes almost no
sense what can I say sweetheart I can't
help you out in that department it
doesn't help that the film was
consistently compared to the much better
received who frame named Roger Rabbit
which has an easy to follow mystery
narrative there's a reason cool world
has gone down as one of the most hated
movies of all time despite finding some
success as a cult classic 1987's The
Brave Little Toaster follows the
heartwarming quest of a sentient toaster
and his Appliance friends as they try to
reunite with their lost owner similar to
Pixar's Toy Story which would come years
later the inanimate objects of this
world are all actually alive but pretend
to be dormant whenever a human is around
while the story of The Brave Little
Toaster is easy enough to follow for
audiences what really makes the film so
confusing for younger audiences is just
how intense it is because of its nature
as an independent feature film the
creators were able to put in much darker
themes than what would have been allowed
with rival companies like Disney or
Warner Brothers The Brave Little Toaster
puts its main characters into genuine
life-threatening danger multiple times
throughout the narrative in ways that
genuinely scared its younger audience
one musical number stands out as being
confusingly dark since it depicts living
cars at a junkyard singing about their
worthlessness before being crushed to
death by a large machine in his review
for film freak Central Walter Chaw said
it best when he described the film as
Blade Runner for children the Black
Cauldron stands out as being a lost
Disney movie forgotten to time and
rarely referenced in discussions of the
company's greatest animated Works
nonetheless the film has gained a
significant cult following over the
years thanks to its uniquely dark
complex and intriguing World which
stands out during a particularly slow
era of Animation The Black Cauldron
features a surprisingly stacked cast of
voice performers including John Houston
John Hurt Susan Sheridan and Freddy
Jones although it's gained some
appreciation in recent years the Black
Cauldron is mostly seen as an overly
ambitious and confusing piece of Dark
Fantasy film making based on the book
series The Chronicles of predan the film
follows the Journey of a young man named
Taran who tries to stop the devious
horned King from getting a powerful
Black Cauldron that will help him
completely conquer the world although
critics applauded its animation many
felt the story itself was uninteresting
and underdeveloped Charles Champlain of
the Los Angeles Times succinctly
described the problem with The Black
Cauldron by saying it lacked the
Simplicity and the clarity of Great
Fairy Tales 1978's waterers ship down is
an adaptation of a novel by Richard
Adams which tells the story of a group
of talking rabbits in the English
Countryside the film has become known
for its deeply imaginative lore
compelling narrative and poignant
message on the necessity of preserving
the natural world what makes this
animated film confusing for many viewers
is the D otomy between the cutesy
cartoon look of the rabbits and the
intense for boing imagery of death and
destruction of their environment the
field the field it's covered with blood
Adams created an intricate world with
its own mythology for his novel in a
2014 Reddit AMA he said he even created
an entire rabbit language for the story
called lepine for many watching Waters
ship down this all may be a bit
overwhelming after after all it's a
movie that looks like it would be about
cute little rabbits being cute together
David Robinson of the times noted in his
piece down the rabbit hole and into
Disneyland that people watching without
knowledge of the book beforehand May
struggle to keep up adding that they
might have a little difficulty with the
special lore and language of Richard
Adams rabbit
[Music]
civilization